New studies show that babies are
sinister, conniving villains.
They absolutely do not say that.
Oh Laci, so eager to believe
what the international baby
conspiracy spoon feeds you,
like just another baby.
Mmm, OK.
Laci and Anthony here for DNews,
and over the last couple years,
studies have shown that babies
are much more emotionally
and intellectually aware
than we previously thought.
They are almost too smart.
Or just the right
amount of smart.
Research released
this week shows
that babies can figure
out whether people
are friends or foes based on
shared likes and dislikes.
If a baby as young
as nine months old
sees two people eating and
enjoying the same food,
for instance, they'll assume
that common interests will
make them act friendly
toward one another.
And if those two people don't
seem to like each other,
the baby will
stare more intently
at them trying to
figure out why,
sizing us up, looking for
alliances and weaknesses,
trying to play us
against each other.
Or maybe they're just learning.
Ha!
Also, according to Concordia
University research,
babies as young as
18 months old can
tell when your actions
don't match your feelings.
If you and another
adult are smiling
but arguing trying not to
let the baby know, it knows.
And if you hurt yourself
but try not to yell
or scream so the baby
doesn't get upset,
it can still tell that
you're distressed.
They can see through all
of our lies and tricks.
Or I think they're
just sympathetic to us.
Do you?
Because they fool us constantly.
We used to think that
children couldn't really
lie until the age of four.
But a University
of Portsmouth study
showed that babies
start manipulating us
at six months old, OK?
They fake cry, and they
fake laugh to get attention.
And they even know when
they do something wrong,
and they will fake
pain or distress
to distract you from it.
They're not laughing
at that silly face
you've made 50 times in a row.
They don't think it's funny.
They are distracting
you from the fact
that their baby accomplice is
right behind you on your iPhone
stealing your identity.
Well, there was
that study recently
that showed that
40% of toddlers can
use touch screens before
they can even talk.
Yeah, welcome to the truth.
Anthony, you know, babies,
they're not evil hackers.
No, no, of course not.
They're just innocent
little sweethearts.
We are absolutely
not onto their game.
And we do not want them to
know that our intellects are
superior to theirs and
that they will never
get the upper hand on us.
Do you think they bought it?
No.
Change all your passwords.
On it.